[Music]
all right welcome to endgame exclam with
your host ran mr. then feingold
yes and last week during this class we
looked at my games because you know
they're my games I do what I want to my
class when it's your class people could
fall asleep in your class
that's my class hey stop falling asleep
okay there's tons of people here
hundreds of thousands of pounds that's
how many times there are okay it's a big
class and though there are zero people
here I'm serious there are not zero
people later at least Bensimon these
years okay and then this ruthless and
doofus now the theme of today's lecture
is difficult King and pawn endings not
difficult for some people because
they've seen all these before but now
this ending is a variation on an ending
that happened I'm going to see a year
ago but I could be off by a year but not
that way the other way between two
grandmasters where the game ended
prematurely with the wrong result okay
sort of like having the wrong baby gonna
have a light baby so in this position
White's going up the board because I
said so and why it's always going up the
board so that make it easier for the
next puzzles I'll remind you because you
forgot and if you don't if you if you
don't believe me these numbers over here
sort of help you won and so forth okay
so White's going up even if you don't
remember that otherwise white would
Queen okay and here it looks really good
for white because it's White's move and
white has a king and black doesn't so
white you know does this and then does
this okay it's a very similar position
and a grandmaster game black resigned
okay and unfortunately when the game
ended it was pointed out the disposition
as a draw so resigning was not correct
it was funny but not the correct answer
and the reason it's not a draw is as you
all know like especially Orlando for
example if he was here that if you have
old
leigh-anne H pawn or an ape on it's very
difficult to win so the key move later
the game is for blacks to play you
what's the key what so he's begging the
play later you can do it let's call it a
random student Julian age 5 because in
lots of positions if I play hy than you
take your double date ones aren't going
to win no I mean okay so you have to the
appropriate time when the pawn is that
queening when the pawn is cleaning it's
not a good time to play h5 like now so
the game should continue like this okay
and just before we get into position
where White's going to take all the
pawns
now black plays uh5 okay and if the card
Nakamura would say obviously frankly
ballpark frankly delicious okay and it's
a draw okay that shouldn't be hot
dogging it like that now so this is
obviously a draw however you have to
have some skills to pay the bills this
is obviously a draw also okay why you
guys agree yeah okay so the winning
attempt for white is to play the move
you random a student what's what's
whites only winning attempt King Lear no
no your place for win not a loss now
after King g7 you're you're definitely
not better here you're all talking a
badge now you'll still draw but there's
a move where you try to win if you're
playing the right people you will win
which is most people in the st. Louis
Club Julian give the right answer please
age three yeah okay and now you're not
going to be left with an H pawn you'll
be left with a G pawn with the H bar you
can't beat nobody even Ken Weston draw
not just kidding okay yeah I so could've
easily said Mario yeah why so mean
[ __ ] left okay but that's why he's
famous okay so now black obvious
plays h4 right though the guys laughing
behind you so might not be right but
it's touchmove so you take the fun okay
and then take this week and I play King
f8 and drawn instead of HG yeah and now
you play King f8 as I said so and the
die takes the pawn and now you have 5
legal moves and one of them drawers
I recommend that one let's call it a new
student how does black draw one move
draws you can do it
King g7 very you know authoritative Lee
said it's like somebody who's taught
chess here that's correct and that's
called opposition okay and that's a draw
so in the starting position very similar
position a grandmaster resigned not a
good move
gather you what's going again yeah okay
and so once the once the King gets to f6
we play h5 if we wait and play h5 here
that is too late does it take this with
a king
so that's waited too long and if you do
it earlier you play h5 here but why can
I do it that is I knew was my move I
could see now that that's that's too
early to Italy I still draw here too
I still draw here I'm great okay so h5
draws here and h5 draws in the next
position and instead black resigned
solid and the reason is this looks
incredibly lost because what like king
of doing and taking all your pawns but
because of the h5 move and giving them
the stupid H pawns we can draw
chess is difficult that was sort of the
easiest one still too hard for this
class okay now a long time ago I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say nine years ago but I'm
guessing but it's between seven and
twelve years ago some close there was a
game between Kasparov and as my perish
really I could have looked it up before
the game but that would waste valuable
seconds okay and the final position was
very similar to this it wasn't this but
it was similar and the game was being
shown live on I see
because they were playing in the
olimpiadas semana some strong tournament
okay and I didn't see the game I just
logged into ICC and I was like oh
Kasparov he's pretty good okay and this
was the final position something like
this and it said black resigned and I
was like looking at it in my head using
my genius technique and I was like
uh-huh uh-huh I was like a draw so I was
confused
luckily my good friend and somebody
who's taught here before at V Friedman
we call him FST that's the best title he
can hope for I said was it as a draw and
he said no he had already looked at the
game and he knew this wasn't a draw
now what's funny about that is it turns
out there was a game played in Soviet
Russia when it was Soviet Russia in the
40s with the same position and
supposedly of I don't believe it both
players knew that the end of that game
because the Soviet school of chess
they're talking upon games and so they
knew that this is a win okay the first
two moves are obvious even you guys
would play them okay you move your king
over move your king over move your king
over sorry okay and I was like what's
the problem officer
okay I analyzed the two most obvious
moves concluded they were drawers and I
was correct but then I asked Aviv isn't
this a draw and he said incorrect
there's on the internet so I was
confused I didn't even see him do that
okay and the reason it's incorrect is
because the moves I analyzed were
drawers but I've analyzed the right move
so I analyzed the right move I wouldn't
do what was up if they had kept playing
I want to knew it was up I knew nothing
okay I just showed somebody yesterday
that know-nothing party you guys
familiar with that in the 1850s maybe
yeah what now you know nothing good
you're part of that party okay
I was actually showing a student of mine
that on the internet he didn't believe
in me like there's no nothing funny come
on yeah without the founder I mean
Donald Duck I mean I jump when I played
bridge okay so now I'm giving him too
much credit
less than nothing I know I had a lesson
today with the person who works at the
Hall of Fame and I explained to them for
quite a long time because when I teach I
give all the information I said there
are a lot of people in chests who are
like good players or politician chess
politicians and some of them believe I'm
not one of them but maybe I am one of
them but I'm changing my mind
brush not dress resignation should be
banned
no resigning in chess okay and the
reason when you watch sports on TV I
don't think they're resigning because
they're not allowed to okay and when
you're not the best player in the world
and you watch true grandmasters play and
one of them is up to pawns and the other
guy resigns you're like I'm up two pawns
all the time I never win why isn't
resigning okay and so it's preferable
for the spectators to see some
checkmates going on and for people who
don't play chess who we wanted to get
interested in chess we want to see
checkmate then we can't really argue
like why did he lose and he got
checkmated so this would have been good
for me as a beginner player myself I
would have been like why did I polish
merely resign but I could have seen why
if they had played on tile checkmate all
right so you with some crazy comment and
you won ah
I tell my students never resign now as
you all know I've been married so many
times I can't count but one of my wives
I don't know which one was playing in
the US Championship when I say the US
Championship I don't mean the US Women's
Championship by the US Championship and
she was rated 1800 or so that's a long
story there'll be another video and she
said what do I do
and I was liking it clutch now and I
said I have one piece of advice never
resigned don't resign and when I told my
students that they say okay then they
resign every game okay like my current
wife is a good example
she knows never resign I've said it
thousands of times and she's never been
checkmated she resigns so good
listen to me like she listens everything
else this particular wife did listen to
me and got checkmated all nine games
okay true story and after the tournament
some of their participants are like why
didn't your wife resign when she was
down in seven thousand pieces and I said
I told her she's not a lot of the reason
I said okay
they thought it was insulting when I
said I told her she can't resent it okay
that's here right and you're not
required to resign you plan on so I
don't care my pony resigns or doesn't
resign that's up to you it's not for me
okay you're going to resign when you
play me but you'll have to so in this
position if in the starting position of
the of the end game if black hadn't
resigned I would have learned something
it's that I had asked of even get
embarrassed okay
like I turned an engine on but I'm too
lazy so in this position after you heard
all my rambling now you know that when
you move for white is not not Julian
what's that we're G what you say yeah
I assume you sit here yeah that wins it
not only does it win it wins because
it's black smooth it was white through
Olivia God okay and now black is in
zooms along and he's actually any pawns
you guys understand now I can show you
that okay I didn't see King g5 in the
starting position because I'm not you
know Ilan I'm old even though I wasn't
old bed okay
and there's a tricky move black in play
which isn't very tricky which is King g4
BAM who's tricking whom I said that
correctly by the way you could edit that
to make it long okay so now white makes
any random move they're both good an
extra King takes pawn the sale mmm shows
meaning so it's stolen yeah so obviously
both players do this King g5 room so
blackness resigned it caused problems
like of course okay ridiculous so now I
know this position yes I have up every
day almost right Julian yeah exactly
okay but yeah that's a good thing to
know King g5 and it's your
haha alright next but not last okay this
is a famous puzzle which I've showed
many times and other than Julian even if
you've seen it ten times you still don't
know the answer the true story right
well that guys today he took with the
opponents of the block I can't believe
it
he'll think I'm talking about what when
I was going to like trash talk for like
a year if you took with the rock the
horrible
okay now you're not good enough to solve
this position because he want to show
you the answer you'll be confused so the
truth hurts if you're using your engines
on your phone and you have a good chance
that you're going to get it now I was
shown this position by none other than a
V Friedman who said all this is really
easy because he is the answer okay and
I've solved it in about seven minutes he
made fun of me for all seven minutes
like how did this take you so long and
you're the worst and so forth that is
the last one which I didn't get and then
I showed this to the karo
Nakamura and he didn't solve it he gave
up okay then I showed to a 2,400 player
in Michigan that I know and he also
couldn't solve it so you know some of
you okay to solve this you have to do
lots of sacrificing which is weird and
you have to make waiting moves and
backwards and it's crazy and guess it so
this is an opposition what you don't
know I'm talking to all of you
especially you Ben Simon right what what
you know that you don't know okay yeah
okay now the reason this is difficult to
solve is that most people when I set
this up they think it's white to play
and win when actually it's like to play
and draw and white has one way to draw
if you don't play that way you lose okay
but Orlando knows the answer no see now
you're the smartest guy in the class
you're like no I don't know that that's
hard okay anybody I want to give a crack
head and is not Julian you remember the
answer Julian forgot you forgot
whoaaah I thought after ten times you
remember yeah but you figured it out
maybe all right so you
now this is instantly horrible teenage
2gh resigns that's super resigns yeah
that's not even if they heard that I
would win every time the obvious move is
the first work the most obvious move if
it moves to 3 & 4 a tough what's that
yeah hg okay now the reason black is
better and trying to win is like a mini
king upon endings black has a better
King whoever has the better King is
trying to win White's King is not not so
good okay so King g6 is terrible because
you don't you'll get my fine
now let's trying to win so the correct
move is King h5 now no matter what you
do I'm going to take both of your pawns
okay over the next three moves I'm
taking both of your pawns log X 4 moves
three months and next three moves okay
so you have to figure out how to give
your pawns away now you know the famous
song you've got to give your pawns
anyway can we are we getting in trouble
I know it's a parody Oh good but you can
do it but if it's a known song and I
like to sing and make fun of it that's
okay right because it's a parody yeah
who's the exact words I don't know
Oh even if it's the same words what if I
sing the whole song put yeah okay yeah
all right so the fine gold rule which I
made up was if you have King and pawn
versus King and your king is two squares
in front of your pawn you win so if like
those King here takes the plunge takes
the pawn he wins it doesn't matter where
White's King is because our King has two
squares in front of our fine so you
can't like well I have the opposition
you don't win my Kings on g5 you just
resign so what you'd like to do is one
of two things you want to make blacks
King go back here that you can get the
opposition or you want to make white
black's pawn go forward
you know what I mean so if I'm ping and
pong versus King and the black pawn is
forward then you can draw if the black
pawn is all the way back on f7 mike is
going to win well you can't make the
black King go backwards but you can make
the white pawn go forwards therefore the
answer Julian is g6 yeah so King g6
doesn't work because you don't win my
pond so you don't win then so you take
with H fun okay and now you have to make
the moves you never wanted to make in
your life you have to make it sorry
what's the last move you would make
that's the right answer
yeah f5 you have to make the pawn go
forward okay now this position it
doesn't matter whose turn it is it's
still a draw but White has the distant
opposition however White has three moves
and two of them lose so you better play
the right one not you you know the
answer you figured it out already
horrible what about Rufus is a doofuses
of the triplet okay Nevin Costello more
and Hardy come on yeah so let's ask a
random student then Simon King g1x clam
somebody who teaches chest okay
now you're ready for the King to go
forward so if he goes g4 will go to g2
because aged four will go to h2 or f2
you get your choice diagonal opposition
basis but blacks not as dumb as you look
he plays King's g5 and now White has
five legal moves and only one of them
drawers it's getting harder but you can
do it
King s1 okay and then that's the hard
part's over
yeah King here we play king of two King
here we play Kinji - and king h4 does
everything draw or just king f2 just can
F - Wow
yeah that must be a cool move because
always this drawing okay
and otherwise it's easy we get the
opposition and so forth yeah this is
difficult pawn ending so I can't show
this one it's too easy
okay so the only way to draw this
position is to take ht5 and sacrifice
with your pawns now a lot of you are
like my engine can solve this my engine
is great my engine this my engine that
that's true and if you put this on your
engine it instantly says all zeros and
plays all those moves if you didn't
understand why you'd be like why is my
engine giving all of this funds away
Vikings you want so it's good when
somebody can explain like what's
happening what's happening is we you're
going to lose your pawns anyway and you
want to get the distant opposition for
distant opposition problems this is one
of the toughest because you're getting
two pawns away usually in distant
opposition puzzles I gave you get one
pawn away and you're like hey it was in
the plan anyway
now another difficult puzzle shown to me
by Aviv was this one and the hard thing
about this one is remembering how to set
it up because the white and black pawns
look like somebody switched them okay
and once again White's going this way
and the plans illegally did that
probably the bughouse game you remember
this one ah yeah okay yeah he remembers
okay so this is also this is a white to
play and win but we only have a one hour
class so if I explain the whole thing to
you the class will be over because it's
sort of sort of tricky the first move is
the most obvious move ever all of you
can figure it out well you didn't say
nothing yet
the most obvious move jisub yeah
now the first move for black is also
obvious 1807 all right now again this is
sort of like a distant opposition
problem if we play normally then
unfortunately black gets it well
unfortunately for white black gets is
king here and this is the easiest of
drawers okay this is a 10 west to draw
all the time if he was white you agree
with that statement or you think
sometimes he'd lose I don't think he
could lose with white the director might
not allow it
man no bit about so Ken West is playing
in a period tournament Wow is this an
alternate universe okay well he's a
grandmaster okay
so King takes pawn that don't work there
for the second move is King f5 okay now
if black plays an obvious fashion he
loses an obvious fashion takes the pawn
take the pawn obviously if white plays
King takes pawn does the Feingold rule K
is two squares in front of the ply so we
try to like make the white pawn go
forward but White has the opposition ah
and white wins and black has to move
somewhere lose okay so the obvious King
takes g7 loses to the obvious King takes
g5 therefore we play the trickiest move
possible King GA okay and the idea is
actually very tricky not for you or even
for you it's a little tricky also you're
at the highest rate personally well you
probably are I know when you were
thinking about it before right that's
why you knew you were you really were
nice yeah okay
so after King takes g5 the obvious move
not you black has one move that draws
good luck
you only got four legal moves so there's
like five of you so come on there's like
six people at home watching now while
they're thinking I want to make a
correction to a previous video in the
first video I made here which was
published about a week ago I beat a
German guy in the last round taking away
his I am norm in the Netherlands and I
said after the game
the Germans bought me a beer incorrect
the Dutch bought me a beer at the German
horrible I watched my videos I'm like no
that's not what I meant okay
tourism buy me a beer I can't like what
the Germans did their stuff okay
so after that commercial message what is
the drawing move for black not you you
gotta hear what you're pretty high rated
you not can Sutton
Simon Claudia what's the move yeah II
for now blacks threatening to win only
white white has to play King f4 and drop
now so white takes the pawn and then we
taken of the opposition here you you
agree yeah okay
so Kings is Kings he takes g7 liz's King
G Apes makes King takes g5 not work
because of you for so now this was hard
to find unless you've seen it before
I'll let you answer because your high
rated King g4 do you remember this or
now yeah okay kingi for now if you play
King g7 I said if we already looked at
this it was with King g7 King g5 without
the King James King G throw thrown in
okay so that loses some people play e4
here that also loses takes takes and
opposition okay
so black has two moves that are equally
good and they're the same so we'll just
play one of them man okay now usually
when I show this like a queen let that
don't win you can play Queen I recommend
night-night let's play nice okay thanks
now maybe I shouldn't have take it okay
and now after King takes how does black
draw is there to lose the draw no just
one let's see hold on the only one won't
draws no no that totally breaks the
Finegold rule King f5 wins and King a
sec we talk about trouble you eat for
less interesting because it's right and
then takes and then King g7 opposition
okay so the way to win is actually funny
after king f7 we can take on g5 now now
if we go back to this position when I
took on g5 e 4 was the drawing move
because Claudia said so and he was right
however in this position he 4 does not
draw because White has a move that was
really bad in that position
but now wins although with the King on
g8 is really bad but here it's great
Tessa's hard White has one move that
wins King age six
now if the black king is on g8 now
blacks winning but the black King than
f7 so White's threatening this that's
annoying and if you play King g8 now you
really lose and you can also play King
aged seven which you know is the same
King aged seven and now I play King f6
with the same idea the King g8 and I
take so the answer is White's winning
but after g7 if black finds the really
strong-willed King g8 you have to find
king g4 and then you have to find takes
and King up so not easy to win top girls
and winning is remembering how to set it
up because the puns are funny on the G
file
so actually blacks defending really what
a draw but it doesn't quite work again
for a computer to made in whatever let's
put a million to the second and plays
really well too but it's not very
helpful in explaining it not like that
Simon my Ben okay okay you've already
seen this it's your only hope
okay so again it's white smooth White's
going up otherwise you need to solve
right otherwise white pink we and whites
obviously closer to the pawns than black
in fact White's already defending a V
pawn so white has very obvious winning
method and if white tastes the plan
White's King has three squares in front
of his bond breaking my rule of being
two squares in front okay so if we play
the most obvious wounds ever which is
your forte
okay somewhere doesn't matter obviously
White's winning White's super winning
because Kings three squares in front of
the clock okay
and black would prefer not to lose if
you remember the first puzzle and
Claudia wasn't here so he doesn't say
his remember again he wasn't here in the
first puzzle it was a draw because the
guy who's trying to draw gave his
opponent lots of pawns on the side H
pawns
in this situation black wants to try to
draw by giving white and a pawn if we
had an ape LAN and not a beep one that's
all a draw you agree okay so you have to
realize when you make a move blacks
going to try to give us a to give us
pauna way okay so if we stop that with
the king we're not fast enough
okay and I'll show you because I'm a
nice guy here and you're not fast enough
to draw okay so you can't play king b1
you have to play king c2 and I told you
how black is going to draw so black
plays a4 okay now I told you black was
going to play a three because blacks
gonna play a three if flat doesn't play
a three he just helped white White's
gonna play King takes a four and win and
he didn't move his King over so terrible
so you know glass could have play a
three so if you play the obvious move
King c3 black plays I told you a three
and if you like Oh taking is a dry of a
side pawn I know I'll play b3 and then
this pawn can't Queen which is correct
unfortunately it's very hard to win that
pond it looks easy but if not ok you
can't play King before cuz you'll lose
and if 10 West was your have a lot of
jokes but he's not here so this is now a
draw because the only way for whites are
when the pawn is to recruit like a
Frenchman and you don't even wings upon
I thought you did win the pond but you
know that's actually funny exclam every
legal move drives all of them for both
sides in every position ok so that's an
incredible draw and the reason is king
c3 does nothing in fact if black plays
a3 and white plays b3 I'm glad to have
my king on c2 then I could play King d1
clicker
now you could also try to win because
you're probably thinking what about b4
and I go take the ply well unfortunately
your pawns on b4 that's not where you
wanted if you remember the previous
puzzles the guy who was defending was
trying to make his opponent's pawn go
so his king wouldn't get in front so now
easy draw because White King doesn't get
in front and black plays King v6 next
move
draw okay so if King c3 doesn't win and
you want to win the a pawn you must
always play always puts a rule I am king
b1 which is very funny because if you
played King be won in the starting
position you don't win because the black
claw was na v now the black ones on e4
so the only way to win is to play king
c2 and then King b1 followed then
eventually you just keep repeating and
the opponent resigns because I want to
repeat but none of them got it maybe
Julian maybe
exactly and now we define goals rule
takes effect good rule and wipes King
has two squares in front of the pawn the
only drawing move is King takes pawn
that's more chien that even I can do
every other legal move and it illegal
move loses King takes pawn draws all the
king before the opposition nothing
terrible can you believe that Bensimon
yeah alright so to to repeat always
repeat king c2 king b1 only way to win
and the a4 is the only move otherwise
it's too easy and people who play loop
like king c3 quickly what did you think
black was going to play like you've got
my a3 then king c3 does nothing but king
b1 now III does nothing and here
what's the winning move I think there's
only one winning one liver wins what
what is it b3 wins
I think before doesn't win there there
Terry the one maybe it does
I can't count that quickly you're
younger than me count it there there
carry the one there that looks like a
draw don't know if it wins it doesn't
matter White's winning anyway
rarh but B three wins easily before very
suspicious okay now you guys will all
play these perfectly alright now this
is sort of a puzzle but it's the answer
to a puzzle this is the answer but I
can't tell you the name of the puzzle
because they don't know what the right
moves are now they still 100 K so n is a
Tomsky many times us Women's Champion
who is currently playing in the Women's
World Championship for the US team is
she currently plays that's been over for
two weeks
it's like round three now no no what I'm
saying is will this video be published
while they're still playing the
tournament
that's right foot over four weeks
there's that 50/50 okay now Anna gave me
a puzzle and she said set up a position
where one side has three pawns neither
side has nothing
none of the pawns are doubled or tripled
on different files it's the side with
the three pawns to move and it's still a
draw and it took me a very long time to
figure out the position and this is the
position I figured out eventually but
you don't know how long it took me
she asked me several years ago okay and
what's funny is if this point is on a
two then whites winning chess is hard
and there's another position where you
draw which is the other side of the
board the same position in a mirror okay
so here it's White's turn to play but
with correct play it's a draw which is
amazing as White's up three pawns that's
his move okay now let's see who's man
enough and or woman enough to raise
their hand and try to draw me with black
it is a draw I can't beat you if you
play correctly I got nothing we're not
you raising your hand is this easy for
you you know the answer ah then you
could get it wrong if you were like 800
points worse all right so you oh yeah
I'm playing white yeah in curtain on
skype
yeah the only move that drives and if
it's blacks move in this position blacks
losing both sides are in zooms along
that's why the point has to be on a
three
if the plunge I'm a two we do the same
thing and I play a three okay now you
guys are all confused which I mean you
showed up confused so nothing change and
you're wondering why this doesn't draw
but Julian's not going to tell you kind
of ask the rest of the class let's call
it a random student Claudio how does
white win King a for these random
students are pretty hydrated okay and
the natural King takes fun here it's
obviously a Simpsons joke right you know
that Simpsons episode no yeah yes
superintendent Chalmers is doing an
inspection you want to see if the kids
are smart and Principal Skinner says
let's call in a random student Lisa
Simpson she was the random suit all
right and then we have to keep stopping
the black king and now we stop them
enough and now these are our next five
moves they're pretty good wounds yeah
okay so after King b2 king b5 now it's a
draw because white if white plays a four
it's very hard to play King a4 next move
you can do it when it's hard yeah right
then White's doing well yeah and this is
a dork all usually I would go and buy my
pawn would still be here
yeah man you play like the kids in my
last camp exactly like them yeah hi so
this is a draw because black can get the
put white in deserves wrong position
usually when you're down three pawns and
you guys know what I'm talking about
what Claudia doesn't of a Claudia was
done a lot of material in the last game
I saw him play who are you playing yeah
grab in skein it was a lot of a chill up
so you don't know what I'm talking about
yeah then you can still draw sometimes
if you're very lucky what you won't be
okay least but not last now I've shown
this many times but you forgot if you
take away the F and the G plunge this is
a well-known triangulation position okay
however this same triangulation this is
a real life okay this actually happened
the triangulation position
theory this is practice incorrect go to
your room
this was the 2007 I'm closed US Women's
Championship it might have been 2006 or
a I don't remember was one of them
thanks Evan
I know the players uh chimichanga was
white that's what we called her she went
back to a Mongolia she played for the US
and she's Mongolia now she plays for
Mongolia okay her name is like Batson
Batson Meg
torsion hugs and I'm not kidding that is
her name yeah we call her Jimmy and this
also isn't a drunk when it sounds like
one we went to a Mexican restaurant
during the tournament she did order
chimichangas we got a picture because we
called her chimney so yeah well I
thought she was that's what you said
okay so she was letting in Zegna
zenyatta famous end game player and
white was waiting windy winning winning
and then white was up in exchange than
Worcester to get this position anyway
the game was really taken a long time
game was at least six hours long and
genic was very happy now because she
thought it was a draw and so she was
like loud la la la her folks like start
saying la la la okay and that's a truth
based on a true story yeah my son was
directing a kid's tournament he was a
floor director or like a billion kids so
kids raised their hand and said whatever
the dumbest thing possible is and he
would go up and he would settle disputes
so a kid raised his hand and Spencer
went over this is over ten years ago and
the kid said my opponent is saying long
11 and I was like 150 okay that actually
did me half with this game but it could
have okay so Daniel goes like this like
come on skims over and they move their
King around forever and drew now with
these pawns gone the way you win is by
making a triangle with your king okay
and you can't do that because King F 4
is illegal so with the plums gone this
is a well known win with those plums
it's an unknown position that was first
played in this game and so white tried
to triangulate but you can triangulate
now if you played
very straightforward okay then black
plays G for you take it in still me or
as many of my students have said you go
here and then black wings and they're
like oh so losing is not good okay and
so white knows that's a draw and so
white kept moving her King around hoping
to get this position with black to move
however you've never been so bad however
the weight of win is not to triangulate
there's another way to win okay
and actually the way to win is to get
this position with black to move however
white has an unnecessary thing on the
board very unnecessary
it's your favorite pawn you don't need
it you're like let's my favorite pun I
have six fun that's the one you're going
to Queen you got to get rid of that yeah
because you're not used to cleaning so
you're like I gotta have even material
yeah so after the obvious sort of king
e5 King f8 I can't make their trump card
but I had to do with it I'm sold so I
can't make this flu or the UMSL joke man
well I could you'll just edit it out
yeah okay or you won't
2/3 okay now when the game ended they
were signing the score sheets and that
took a long time because batch of eggs
or sentence you see what I'm saying yeah
that that's why she was so high rated
and that's why as my parish Julian Lama
Jarvis so hydrating their opponents lose
on time wearing the name on the square
sheet like shock we are mande flag king
ah God okay as my parsley leaves
opponents only hope is his first name
zurab that's only five letters okay so
after the game was done they're signing
the score sheets there was a race
between goal KO and Irina crush to show
them the wind I actually don't know who
won the race they ran to the board and
said our whites winning rawr okay in
this position the winning move which I
kept telling you is you you want answers
are you
f7 right right now didn't did never
thought of f7 never didn't occur to them
at all yeah also black black just so I'm
going to draw and then like f7 flex like
oh yeah that one
neither player size seven because that's
the pawn you don't give away that's the
fun you're going to clean you got to
give that away now you all know the
position with an empty board or there's
white funds here in here and there's a
black King here and blacks just moving
asking back and forth the only way to
win is to sacrifice your advance fund to
avoid sale mate which is what you're
doing here
you sacrifice your advanced pawn and now
we get that position we wanted you don't
need the F pawn we're going to take all
the other pawns and then I think it's
called shouldering but I don't know yeah
and outflanking here whatever yeah and
we went in gray then you take all the
funds so like the computer announces
meet in like one second and the game
though draw
I keep counting and I keep getting seven
you said less than seven seven P
stabilization 2007 incorrect right and
like I'm correcting it yeah not not in
2007 even now you have to like pay for
it or if you have the right phone this
is the wrong phone the Apple if you have
an Android you can get seven piece on
your phone free yeah unless they change
the narrative to the iPhone yeah but my
friend did he's like I've sent these
tablebases free I like what I could get
seventies tail this on the internet or
as I pay I've never paid for software I
mean I pay legally for all my software
so you're shocked and appalled that
white didn't even think or try of seven
you can't even believe it you've never
blundered in your life now I know it's
you
oh man this ski went on a long time
white was like King D for king he for
King d5 and there was never a win tried
everything but f7 now a lot of my
students try f4 at some point at some
point right and then you you take it it
has to draw right because oh no it
doesn't have to draw in fact I think it
has to win no no but this is definitely
draw I guarantee this drawings yeah g4
g4 might lose though yeah and I move my
King back somewhere f7 what King e6 that
was a Vista Lee this isn't winning maybe
King g3 is better
probably because I want to play King f3
after king f5 so I'm going to allows the
vitamins Simpson stroke this might win I
don't know but I know I know
taking an F word run yeah epic bikes
probably waiting upon I think that's
going to be up upon yeah so f4 never
works as you take it and you got nothing
yeah and now in this position now you
can try f4 and now G again blacks
looking good it's a draw but I'll take
black Vincent draw so yeah just f7 in
any position wins after white was trying
all that stuff just
at some point but never TSA f7 doesn't
win it's white smooth
ah you mean if but but King at faking g6
resigning
so that's never going to happen yeah
blacks never going to get those systems
like King F fades and white or anyone
horrible
this should never let you teacher clash
I hope you never have all right you guys
at home don't know why that's funny but
we do yeah
alright and as Julian forgot to say at
the end of his class class is dismissed
[Music]